no matter where you land in the
temperamental landscape you're going to
have your Associated faults and
temptations you've got a goal and you'll
see that as you progress towards the
goal there'll be obstacles that emerge
and some of them you don't want to
confront it's why it's useful to order
your room chaotic room makes you anxious
why too many Pathways man people don't
really repress the things they don't
want to face they just fail to unpack
them you want a horizon of ever
expanding possibility we're built to
walk uphill and when you reach the
Pinnacle of the Hill you want to stop
and appreciate the vision but the next
thing you want is a higher Hill in the
distance